hello John Perry here you are watching
the stated casually Channel welcome to
my new miniseries evidence for evolution
in your own backyard you know we often
think that we need to go to a museum or
dig up fossils to find evidence but it's
actually all around us all of the time
in this series I will show you things
that have caught my eye either literally
in my yard or at least in the immediate
world around me in the woods or at the
park or in the pond nearby my house even
in the gardening shop which is what
we'll look at today actually yesterday I
dropped a friend off at the airport and
on the way home I stopped by a little
roadside gardening shop just to kind of
stretch my legs and you know see what
they had around in there and I found two
plants two succulent species that I had
never seen before
one was a plant native to Madagascar
named mother of thousands it's called
that because it appears to have dozens
of quote babies growing off of its
leaves and you actually can plant them
they'll turn into full adult plants but
that's another story for another time
the plant of interest here was a second
plant one native to the extremely dry
environments of South West Africa and
it's popularly called the string of
pearls
it has spear shaped leaves that at first
I mistook for fruits or some sort of
seed pod now knowing next to nothing
about plants and their evolution I
immediately got out my phone and started
reading first Wikipedia and then I
wandered on to a bunch of scientific
journals I started reading the actual
primary research about these plants and
it turns out that a succulent and by the
way this was news to me is any plant
that has evolved elastic swellable water
holding flesh either in its stems
branches leaves or all three flesh that
allows the plant to store water to
survive in dry climates the thing about
this that was new to me the thing I
didn't know before reading about this is
that succulents do not belong to a
single evolutionary clade biologists
used to think that they did and I used
to think that they did but by carefully
comparing different traits reproductive
strategies flower Anatomy different ways
in which water is actually stored in the
tissues of these plants
and then also the genetics now that we
can compare genomes all these studies
have shown scientists that the succulent
trait has actually evolved multiple
times independently in different tissues
of different plants now this actually
sort of makes sense because all plants
and animals of course hold water in
their tissues which can shrink up a
little bit or swell up a little bit
depending on how much water there is
this means that all plants are already
sort of primed to evolve this trait when
needed the extreme water holding tissues
and succulents are just a variation that
often evolves when plants have to deal
with extremely dry environments after
learning this I was curious are there
intermediate species in my own backyard
are there plants that are sort of like
succulents but not really quite
succulents and sure enough I found one
this plant right here I have no clue
what species it is it is extremely
rubbery here my curiosity got the best
of me and I started pulling apart part
of the flower stem here and it's it's
amazing how much liquid there is inside
especially compared to the other plants
in the yard and when I broke up in one
of the leaves it was filled with this
gel-like substance so here we have a
plant that's not I wouldn't really call
it a succulent but it's very succulent
like beautiful example of a transitional
species by the way if you happen to know
what this species is let me know in the
comments section I'd love to learn more
about it most plants that we call cacti
or cactuses are also considered to be
succulents stem succulents because they
hold water in their stems
cactus leaves and most species have been
modified into spines and are almost
completely dry most house plants that
are marketed as succulents are actually
what we call
leaf succulents the flesh of the leaves
is the part that is swollen up to
contain all the water of all the leaf
succulents in existence the string of
pearls has to be the most extreme
whereas most plants have flat leaves it
has the exact opposite of a flat leaf it
has a perfectly spherical leaf nearly
perfectly spherical each leaf has a
sliver of clear tissue running along the
top called a leaf window the function of
a leaf in most plants is of course to
capture as much sunlight as
at a safe intensity for photosynthesis
being thin and flat gives most leaves a
huge surface area to collect that
sunlight the drawback of course is that
flat leaves also have a lot of surface
area where they can lose water to
evaporation a sphere of course is the
best possible shape if you want to avoid
evaporation because it has the smallest
possible surface area to volume ratio of
any other shape that's great when it
comes to water conservation in the
desert but it also means that there is
less surface area to collect sunlight
that's where most web sites claim that
the leaf window comes in the section of
clear skin you see here which sort of
glows when the plant is backlit like
this super pretty this is a fairly rare
trait in plants it's usually only found
in succulent species that hide most of
their body underground here the windows
function is fairly obvious it focuses
light down into the leaf so the plant
can perform photosynthesis even though
it's hiding from the outside world
people assumed that string of pearl
succulents were doing the same thing the
windows were an adaptation to absorb
more light through the leaf but a series
of experiments trying to test this claim
found that if you cover the leaf windows
it does not affect the plant's ability
to photosynthesize it might be that in
this species leaf windows are simply
belly buttons they're just a byproduct
of leaf development and they're useless
in mature leaves I actually have an
alternative idea which I'll test during
a leaf dissection in a future video
if the photosynthetic tissue is more
rigid than the window tissue the window
might simply serve to relieve tension so
the leaves can swell and contract safely
when they absorb and lose water if you
want to see that dissection make sure
you're subscribed to my youtube channel
and click the little notification bell
now whether or not the leaf window
serves a survival function or it's just
a byproduct of development it's obvious
that the leaves of this strange plant
are highly specialized for maximum water
storage with this in mind I thought to
myself if evolution is true and if this
plant has close living relatives those
relatives should represent intermediates
something between the string of pearls
perfectly round leaves
and the more typical flat leaves of
other plants so I did a quick little
google search to figure out which plants
are most closely related and boom
hypothesis confirmed its closest known
cousin is senecio radicans its leaves
are far less specialized in shape making
them a near-perfect intermediate between
a more typical plant and the extreme
string of pearls succulent it even has a
leaf window that seems to be
intermediate as if that weren't enough
evidence that these succulents must have
evolved from more typical plants that
existed in past here is another close
relative also living in southern Africa
senecio Barbour tonica's its leaves are
less specialized still and in place of a
leaf window and has a simple groove on
top of each leaf from this we can use a
bit of inductive reasoning to conclude
not with certainty but at least with a
fair amount of confidence that the
string of Pearl succulent with its
highly unique ball like leaves and well
the fine leaf windows evolved from a
less extreme ancestor similar to senecio
Barbour tonica's as it slowly adapted to
drier and drier climates so there you
have it a bit of evidence for evolution
in your own backyard or at least in a
gardening center near you I'm John Perry
stay curious
it makes long drives to and from the
airport way more entertaining
let me show off my brand-new t-shirt
designed by artist Jordan Culver you can
purchase one at the link below in the
video description and by doing so you
support my channel's the stated casually
channel which are watching right now and
these stated clearly channel the t-shirt
features a Corvette acro hanging out
with his long-lost cousin a
dromaeosaurus
and it comes in the you know typical
t-shirt and then uh women's cut as well
so yeah go check it out link is in the
video description
you